chantal vient de passer toute la semaine
en mer avec sa famille elle ou un
catamaran depuis dix ans et cette année
encore elle revient ravi c'était sympa
ça bouge un peu mais c'était sympa
vraiment y'a pas d'âge et non pas du
tout on a connu pire on a connu 4 en
plus on a eu un avantage de voir des
dauphins de voir les tortues qui est
plus rare de l'autre côté non il faut
reconnaître que c'était une belle
aventure serait une belle aventure qui
se termine toujours ici pour les loueurs
et le skipper avec un contrôle
obligatoire du bateau comme chaque année
donc le rituel est le même fiche et
stylo en main soit aux quatre
techniciens viennent pour contrôler ces
catamarans aujourd'hui 24 bateaux sont
inspectés cabine et extérieur et de
nombreuses questions sont posées
très bien on a les manifestations comme
ça souvent il ya beaucoup de gens sur
les bateaux donc c'est des fois des
trampolines ou alors les bateaux se
mettent à couple et donc il ya quelques
quelques chocs
sinon les enceintes un peu trop forte
mais mais bon ça va dans l'ensemble les
gens faites quand même attention parce
que sur le nombre de bateaux
il ya quelques cas sont rien de comme je
disais rien de rien de
ça suppose qu'on fonctionne sur la
caution alors pas forcément parce qu'il
y en a certains oui après on prend
toujours un petit peu il ya toujours un
petit peu déçu c'est aussi dans le pour
certaines choses mais sinon on aurait
par exemple pour le cas là du winch 2 ce
matin mais ça a été pris sur la potion
sur les contrôles généraux de ce matin
rien de très grave à signaler
certains bateaux ont dû en revanche être
nettoyée de fond en comble bon quand je
suis entré dans le bateau qui avait
agressé elle fait c'était ok c'était mon
fils ait en partie compenser la défaite
surprise de l'avis de tous il y a eu
moins de location de catamaran est ce la
configuration du tour ou sur la côte
caraïbe
le prix de la location entre 6000 et
8000 euros
les réseaux sont multiples c'est
professionnels ont enregistré six
bateaux de moins par rapport à l'an
dernier